three years for this inquiry
can I have another pandemic by then I
mean these public inquiries do take a
long time and they can be a very
difficult processes as well I mean we've
just come to the end of the Manchester
arena public inquiry something that I'm
very familiar with of course my own
constituency and that's taken many many
years but they are difficult and they do
take a long time and they do cost a lot
of money but what I would say is they
they do get to the heart of the matter
they do get the answers they do get some
accountability for for those who've lost
people for those who are involved for
those who are on the front line
um so they I think they are important
processes even though they can take a
long time Ring Of Steel around Care
Homes is what we were told by the then
Health secretary Matt Hancock at one of
his ministers saying she wouldn't say
that
um how do you interpret what happened at
the time well I actually raise this
matter in prime minister's questions
right at the start of the around this
time of the pandemic because my
husband's a a doctor and he told me what
was happening in hospitals which was
that people were being discharged to
Care Homes without being tested without
knowing whether they had covered or not
and I actually raised it in prime
minister's question on Zoom when we were
back on zoom in in that time and it's
quite clear it was clear at the time and
it's clear now that people were being
discharged from from hospital
when many of them had contracted covert
and that spread and there was a real we
had a real problem with covert in care
homes in this country and that I think
is one of the reasons that we saw the
high death toll in this country the
government there weren't enough tests so
the government just couldn't test people
well there weren't enough tests but they
could have prioritized that test they
could have had a different way of of
dealing with that but at the time there
was very quick discharging uh in into
Care Homes to kind of move people out of
hospitals so I don't think that was that
I mean look we'll see what the inquiries
got to say I'm not going to sit here is
judging jewelry when there is this very
detailed work going on but I think it's
it's clear for all to see those who are
working in hospitals those who are
working in Care Homes the families of
those in Care Homes as well was that
that was that there were challenges here
and there was a quick spreading of covid
through Care Homes when they didn't need
need to be I think perhaps talk to me um
about this young woman relatively young
woman
who has been sentenced
um to um you know the best part of two
years in not a bit more actually in jail
for taking
abortion pills when her baby her unborn
baby was 32 weeks old I mean it's a very
complex concerning uh difficult case and
I think it really does need looking into
now the government needs to look into
and come up with better guidance and
clearer sentencing rules about these
kind of cases because clearly it's it's
very difficult and you know it's hard to
hear about somebody feeling so in
distress and and so at the the situation
that they were that they aborted their
own child so late on in their pregnancy
which is something that obviously uh is
is wrong and not what we would want to
see happen but to sentence to to such a
long time somebody in that situation we
do have to look at in whose interests is
is that in and that's why I think the
government now should I think it's very
clear that that judges and the courts
don't really have the guidance they need
in terms of of how to deal with some of
these cases and we should look at that
to that end do we need to end abortion
related prosecutions well I think that's
what box got to be that's got to be
looked at I mean I don't well I think in
in this particular case it feels it
feels to me a very very very harsh
outcome for somebody who's clearly uh in
distress you know during uh covid who's
got three other children who are now uh
without their their mother who's who's
in prison
um you know it is against the law to
terminate a pregnancy so those laws do
exist in that sense it is a it is a
crime but I think the the uh the
sanctions need to to be fit that
situation I think that's what needs
urgent uh looking at and I know my
colleagues uh on the labor front Branch
will be asking those questions to that
end though do we need to end abortion
related prosecutions but possibly
um but you know there may be other
circumstances I don't know that that may
be uh that may be appropriate for other
reasons but I think in these kind of
cases uh criminal prison sentences I I
don't think are the right outcome yeah
32 weeks pregnant there's got to be some
mental health challenges there have
absolutely somebody especially in covid
and somebody clearly who's now you know
very very remorseful and you know whose
life has been has been ruined by this
and is now spending time in prison away
from her for her own children and that's
not going to help her it's not going to
help her children I don't think it's
particularly in the in the public
interest in this case
um talk to me about just stop oil and of
course the taxpayer we're told four and
a half million pounds over the last six
weeks alone that's on top of the seven
and a half million spent by forces
dealing with just stop oil action uh
last year
um
should you be associated with an
organization like this even if it is
indirectly because the guy who supports
you also supports just stop oil well
we're not associated with uh just stop
oil and their tactics and and what
they're doing are completely
unacceptable and we've been very uh
clear about that in many different uh
ways and you know we have people who are
donors to to the labor party because
they support labor party policies and
they may give
philanthropically to to a wide range of
other organizations we can't be
accountable for all those other
organizations that all people who
support the labor party also support
whether that be as members or whether
that be as uh as donors but we we are
really clear that the
um tactics being used by just stop stop
oil are completely unacceptable they are
disruptive they're counterproductive as
well in terms of of what they're trying
to to promote and there's no question
about that and we are not associated
with them
um but neighbors just voted against more
Proto process Crackdown laws haven't you
what's your plan to curb these sort of
protests well as quite quietly well as
the police themselves have said they
already have the powers they need to
stop these protests sometimes they are
using them sometimes they're they're not
using them as effectively but the police
have themselves said they already have
the powers to stop these kind of
protests what we saw yesterday was yet
again the government trying to seek
headlines in creating a a division in
Parliament they were bringing back
through what these Arcane sort of Henry
VII Powers kind of stop them doing stuff
like this well no they're not the police
already have those Powers so the
Government tried through a bill to to
bring in what they were bringing in uh
last night Parliament both houses of
Parliament rejected that it wasn't then
able to be brought through so they've
used these other well called sort of
Henry VII powers to kind of get round
the Parliamentary process and and as
drafted you know we think that they
would have
um other unintended uh consequences so
the police already have we've already
passed lots of legislation over recent
years around these kind of issues and
the police already have those Powers let
me just ask you quickly Before I Let You
Go um Do You Believe Boris Johnson or
Rishi sunak when it comes to the uh spat
about the House of Lords well this is
just like some kind of soap opera isn't
it I mean you couldn't really make it up
um to be honest I find the whole thing
unedifying I mean that the fact that a
former prime minister who is currently
under investigation by the Privileges
committee ahead of the covert inquiry
which had just discussed sort of taking
place actually even getting an honors
list you know I find that pretty uh
despicable personally so who said what
to who and who should have been on that
list or or otherwise I don't really care
about I don't think you should have had
the list in the first place